[relaxing music]
Regardless of where you like
or in what time period you look,
you'll find that
humans are always making music,
and the music that we make
is similar in certain ways too.
And this sort of thing
might seem obvious to us
just because it's
what we're used to already.
But when we see this
kind of global pattern,
it suggests that there's
something in our biology
and in how
we humans have evolved
that makes it
so commonplace in the world.
So if some song types
like lullabies are grounded
in human biology and evolution,
does that mean that they can
then transcend
cultural
and linguistic barriers?
And if that's the case,
are these types of human songs
a universal language?
So to test this question,
what we did is we put together
a large archive of 118
recordings of songs
recorded all around the world.
They were used
as dance songs, lullabies,
healing songs and love songs
in their original locations.
And we recorded these songs
from 86 different societies
around the globe.
So a really diverse
set of musical stimuli.
And then we took these songs
and played them
to an equally diverse
group of participants.
So we have around 6,000 people
from 49 industrialized societies
and three relatively
isolated societies.
And so in total,
we have about 31 languages
that these people are speaking.
So this is a really diverse,
representative group of people.
And we asked
all of these participants
to listen
to each of the songs and choose
what context they thought the
song was originally used in.
And what we found
when we analyzed the data
that we had
was that regardless of where
in the world
these participants were from
or what language they spoke,
participants were able
to identify dance songs,
lullabies and healing songs
all at above chance levels.
We in our lab
think that it's because music
probably evolved around
two main functions.
One would be in the context
of soothing babies,
because song is such an honest
signal of you
actually attending to them
and showing you that.
Showing them
that you care. Right.
So lullabies
may have developed
as a really honest
signal of affection
and being that
for your children.
So we think that's one way
that music may have developed.
But we also think that song
may have developed in tandem
with dance and in creating
coalition and human groups.
So this would have
a really strong
evolutionary pressure, right?
If you want human groups to be
well coordinated.
You want to be able
to coordinate
bodily motion together.
You want to encourage
things like shared rhythm,
synchronizing work.
And music just functions
as a very efficient way
to get people in sync
in that sense.
I think the main takeaway
is that we have evidence
that human song
is this really fundamental
aspect of the human experience
and is likely shaped
by our biology
and human evolution.
So this is really something
so fundamental to humanity
that also seems to unite us
in the way that we go about it.